This is Green Beat for a healthier planet.
Most people go to a hotel to relax,...
...but these permanent guests are keeping busy making honey...
...and pollinating the rooftop herb garden...
...at Vancouver's Fairmont Waterfront Hotel.
Bee butler Michael King is enthusiastic about his charges...
...because of their role in pollinating much of the world's agriculture.
Their ability to navigate, their ability to feed themselves,...
...their ability to feed us as a result of what they do.
The Fairmont Waterfront Hotel is a green hotel...
...certified by Green Key Global,...
...an environmental group that specializes in the hotel industry.
There's a complimentary parking for electric vehicles...
...and guests are served the honey produced on-site.
The hotel also promotes sustainability with its rooftop garden,...
...which helps save rainwater and insulates the interior of the building.
The hotel says it's on a mission to be certified zero waste...
...by the end of next year through reusing, repurposing and recycling.
I'm Rebecca Ward for VOA's Green Beat.